Drew Ferguson and members from all over
the country some here in Texas Jake is
here in Texas but from from Florida from
North Carolina Michigan California just
all over all over the country so um you
know today it's it's kind of uh
Groundhog Day if you will and sadly
nothing has has changed if anything
things have gotten worse uh you know we
toured we did several different things
we started the day by visiting with
border patrol and touring the new
processing center that they have and
it's you know a nice AC facility 153 153
000 square feet but the bulk of the
agents are in the processing center and
they all they want is to be back out in
the field
and this processing center isn't free
this processing center costs 18 million
to create and it costs in the taxpayers
12.3 million a month so this this
problem isn't getting worse it's
supposed to house a maximum of a
thousand people today it housed over
1300 uh and and in other times it's
housed over two thousand so uh this
crisis hadn't got any work any any
better I'm I tell you what I've been
here over and over and over again this
is my district constantly uh We've
brought different delegations to Eagle
Pass and the thing I am most concerned
with is the terrorists uh uh possibility
of folks coming over but a close second
is our border patrol agents I mean these
are men and women these are mothers and
fathers and they are having to you know
recover dead bodies every single day now
what does that do to you when you're
fishing children out of the river when
you're uh you know uh migrants dying
very terrible deaths there's a there's a
deep Scar and there's a deep
Darkness hole that I see within the
agency that I see within the border
patrol and I'm worried about them I
worry I'm worried about them I'm worried
about their families and that's one
takeaway that we need to have is that
these these record numbers there's
somebody that is processing these people
and that's border patrol agents there's
somebody that is pulling them out of
these Rivers when they're drowning when
they're dying and that's border patrol
agents we can't forget them and their
family one other thing we get too is
very important that I bring groups down
and we talk about the Border we security
is clearly important to us but there's a
broader conversation in Eagle Pass and
anywhere along the border and that
conversation
is a discussion on immigration reform
it's a discussion on you know the legal
traffic legal immigration legal process
that is completely broken it's also
about doing more talking or doing more
listening than talking and we were able
to have a round table with uh the mayor
of Mayor Salinas here in Eagle Pass with
uh Business Leaders with with uh just
everyday people and have this
conversation and I'm grateful that my
colleagues from all over the United
States have come to see it firsthand and
I'm excited to see as we go forward the
changes that the Republican party is
going to do in order to secure this
border but also have a broader
conversation on what we need to do to
fix it not only today but going forward
I want to turn the mic over to uh
Congressman Drew Ferguson you know he's
on our our leadership team it means a
lot for me for him to come out here
Eagle Pass isn't necessarily an easy
place to get to and he's just did an
incredible job leading us and leading
our conference uh Drew Ferguson
um Tony thank you for for putting this
together
for members of Congress to come from
around the country to actually see
what's happening on the border it's
important that we do it but it's also
incredibly eye-opening to see what's
happening in the detention centers to
see what's happening
um just a little while ago we are on the
uh we were standing on the bridge over
to my right and we see border patrol
agents coming to pick somebody up in the
river
um the hazards are real what's happening
to America is real and what's happening
to the folks that are crossing this
border many times they are victims and
what's shocking to me is how normal the
chaos has become
to think about the things that are
happening here right now
and people are becoming desensitized to
it and that is a very very position for
America and Americans to be in
the fact that we have a hundred and
fifty three thousand square foot
facility that we're processing about
1300 migrants every 36 hours and it's
costing the American taxpayer about a
third about a thousand dollars per
migrant for them to be there for 36
hours is unsustainable so we're getting
them through this process in a very
orderly fashion again it seems normal
and then they're normally going out to
parts of America that we don't know
the scary part about that is is that
there are over 500
000 getaways that we don't we don't know
who they are that are coming across that
have gotten across this border five
hundred thousand those are people the
people that are coming into the
detention centers want to get caught
because of this process because they
want to be they want to come into the
country and they know that there's no
ramifications for them it's this huge
number of people that aren't coming
through the detention centers that are
just getting away and what's scary is we
don't know who those people are Tony
mentioned the terrorists that are on the
watch list how many terrorists have come
across our border how many rapists how
many how many folks that mean to do us
arm the number of members of the cartel
that are operating illegally on this
side of the Border we don't know who
they are and that should terrify
Americans so I will tell you we are we
stand committed to create change
to look ahead to making sure that this
Administration and our and our
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle are aware of what's going on and I
would encourage them and invite them to
come down to the border to see this
firsthand they cannot continue to hide
behind the label of blissful ignorance
and not and pretend they don't know
what's going on here so Tony thank you
again with that I'll turn it over to my
colleague from Michigan Tim Wahlberg
well thank you and I think we uh first
and foremost have to say we are here
supporting the the brown the green and
the blue
uh those law enforcement officers
that are put in place to carry out the
law I'm Tim Wahlberg I represent
Michigan 7th District my district goes
from Lake Michigan and the border of
Illinois to the border of Canada in Lake
Erie
I've often said to my constituents that
we are a border County we are border
district and a border state in Michigan
because we have the impact of what's
what's taking place even here at the
southern border we have the fentanyl
that's coming into Jackson Michigan and
impacting people's lives and now has
expanded again when we have thought we
were getting that under control just a
couple years ago
but today I also found out in listening
Customs borders Patrol the impact that
we have with 30 of our agents
who are keyed in and operating down here
through the computers to to assist in
getting names back and doing background
checks so the impact of what's taking
place here where we stand has also been
assisted by agents in Detroit
making it clear that this is a nation
that is full of border states we have to
get control down here but I think a
thing I saw today more than anything
else
is that a nation I think in its
framework in our DNA
is open
to the World open to others who would
want to come here who would want to
participate in this great American idea
who add to our DNA as well and yet
because of what's going on with illegal
immigration that's been pushed even more
with this Administration we're dealing
with now that has allowed law and
lawlessness to be a way that you can get
across because you're not enforcing the
laws
I've been impacted to say why are we not
expanding the ability to do the law by
having the magistrates to hold the
hearings in a timely fashion to take to
say to people who want to get here for
whatever reason you're welcome to try
but we're going to follow the law and
we're going to use the law as
exponentially as as possible we're going
to get you across we're going to
adjudicate if you're deserving to come
we want you here
I know the farmers in Michigan that need
workers whether it's in the dairy
industry or in the fields would love to
have a quicker process to get people to
do the jobs and then the ability for
them to go back if they want to do that
that doesn't take place without Law and
Order that says our border is open at
the gates
comes through the gates do it legally
sign the guest book
and we will work well with you
I appreciate what I've seen here today
with Customs and Border with Immigration
Services
Etc and the local communities in dealing
with a tough problem we have to find a
way in a bipartisan way
if at all possible if not
find a way to get a majority that says
this has to stop
for the human suffering and the human
abilities that can come through an
orderly arrangement here at the border
so it's been great to be here with Tony
Gonzalez appreciate the invite to come
down it's good to have seen this I know
what I saw two years ago when I was in
McAllen and I saw the so-called cages
that were in cages and weren't filled I
saw early transfer what I see her today
shouldn't be happening except for bad
policy and so now I turn it over to my
friend from North Carolina David Rouser
thank you Tim Tony thank you for
organizing uh this tour and I also want
to absolutely thank our law enforcement
particularly our border patrol for the
tremendous job that they do under very
very very very difficult
circumstances
you know there's some Universal truths
that you just can't ignore
and one is you get more of what you
incentivize
you know when President Biden came out
and he reversed the Trump policies that
worked so well
it incentivized illegal immigration it
incentivized all these Crossings
and the unfortunate truth is
led to a humanitarian disaster
has led to a drug disaster
enriching cartels like they've never
been enriched before
has led to crime and much more crime to
come
hundreds of thousands of getaways we
don't even know who these people are or
where they are
I personally will be shocked if in the
next two to five years we don't have a
significant 911 style attack if we don't
turn this around and turn this around
immediately
this Administration
needs to come down here
see what's going on acknowledge the
disaster and repeal these open border
policies
I now will turn it over to my friend
Carlos Jimenez from Florida
thank you and I want to I'm Carlos
Jimenez I represent Florida's 26th
congressional district that Miami and
the keys and I want to thank Tony
Gonzalez for hosting us here today I
want to thank our chief Deputy Whip Drew
Ferguson also for being here today along
with my other other colleagues this is
my third trip down to the border every
time I'm thinking well maybe just maybe
you know it's getting better but
actually it's just getting worse and as
some of my colleagues have already said
we're going to be we're going to have
over 2 million
immigrants crossing the border that we
know of that that are being processed
you know through our through our system
we will have 500 000 that got away but
there's also estimates that's only half
of the people that actually got away
there's another five hundred thousand
dollars that we don't even know got away
that's another million people that are
in the United States and we don't even
know what what they're doing who they
are or or where they're going and so why
is it so important for me a guy from
Florida to uh to come come here well it
in the processing facility that I was at
today well I spoke to you know a number
of the migrants there since I speak
Spanish and I asked him where are you
from uh well they were all either from
Cuba or Venezuela and Miami is the
center of both the Venezuela and Exile
community and the Cuban Exile community
so most of those folks I expect will
make their way to Miami and now more
Cubans have crossed the border here
the last year than we had during the
Marielle boat lift and so yes it is an
issue for for me representing Miami and
uh and the keys and so when I look at
the policies it's very it's pretty clear
that the president knows exactly what
he's doing mallorca's knows exactly what
they're doing and what's happening right
now is what they want to happen and so
they want the chaos they want completely
open borders because you know their own
people are telling them what they have
to do to stop you know this Insanity of
what's Happening Here and by the way
this is also costing migrant lives over
150 migrants just in this sector have
died this year many many more than were
in the past and so it's humanitarian
crisis as some of my colleagues also
said we're making the bad guys rich on
the other side of the border the cartels
I asked them hey how much is it how much
did it cost you to cross oh it cost me
two thousand it cost me three thousand
okay per person
to cross and there's thousands and
thousands and thousands so imagine how
much money is going American dollars are
going into the hands of the of the
cartel and then on the other side what
they're doing they're bringing guns
they're bringing drugs enough drug drugs
especially fentanyl to kill every single
one of us maybe a hundred times over uh
and so again you know the cartel is
almost declaring war on the United
States there's over a hundred thousand
people died of overdoses last year in
the United States many of them died
because of Fentanyl and what are we
doing about it we're just letting it
come on in and so again I put this all
on Joe Biden President Biden uh you have
to change policies uh admit that you're
wrong and uh and really help the
American people is there any Spanish
language uh media here okay I'll say
something in Spanish
foreign
La culpa a pero okay
is
that I'm going to turn it over to
to uh Congress Congressman Jake Elsie
from from Texas
thank you to my good friend Tony for
bringing us down here you do this an
awful lot and you're the busiest man in
Congress right now with everything
that's going on in your District
uh my name is Jake Gales here from Texas
Six just south of Dallas I'm like my
friend Tony I'm a 20-year Navy veteran
I'm a warrior and a protector and a
husband and a father and the river
behind me represents asymmetric Warfare
being waged against the United States
every day
you know Alejandra majorcus has now told
Congress twice that the border is under
control
yet
this last fiscal year since October 1st
155 people have died in these Waters
behind me
women children
the border patrol has to go pick those
Folks up if you're listening to my voice
or watching my face right now imagine
for you if you will for just a moment
what it might be like to have to take a
dead body a dead baby out of that River
there's stress associated with that and
I haven't seen Alejandro mallorcas or
our borders are the vice president come
down here one time to witness that kind
of atrocity this is a human catastrophe
140 000 getaways did you know that
Vladimir Putin invaded Ukraine with
fewer people than that but 140 000
getaways in this fiscal year alone in
this United States do you think any of
them are MS-13 going throughout our
entire country
terrorizing our cities with drugs human
trafficking
and gunfire
December 7 1941 to August 14 1945.
during World War II 416 800 Americans
perished defending our nation overseas
this last year 105 000 Americans died
from fentanyl overdoses in our backyards
our bedrooms and in our homes within our
own borders
World War II we lost 305 Americans every
day
in this war it's 287 Americans every day
to fentanyl I ask you does that sound
like asymmetric Warfare for you it does
to me the chemicals being provided by
the communist Chinese and put together
by the cartels in Mexico
they should be declared a clear and
present danger to the United States of
America and treated as such immediately
so if you say the borders under control
Mr mayorkas it's either you're doing it
on purpose or you're lying to us either
way it's time for you to be impeached
this is a terrible place to be we
shouldn't be talking about this but we
have to and it needs to be addressed
immediately
so Tony thanks again for your time I now
turn this over to congresswoman Julia
letlow from Louisiana
thank you and thank you Congressman
Gonzalez for inviting me here today
um
we see it every day on television we
read it in the papers but there's
nothing quite like seeing it firsthand
and I can tell you today as I stand
before you as Mom of a four and a
two-year-old
my heart is absolutely shattered
talking to border control about bringing
babies that have drowned out of this
very River
does something to your heart that it's
hard to recover
and not only that
but the journey that these migrants have
been on to get here to this River than
to cross it and then to where they're
going after that is so treacherous
that it just absolutely has shattered me
and don't get me wrong all of us parents
here know that we want a better life for
our children but there are ways to enter
this country legally and what we have
happening right here on this border is
not working and so I echo my colleagues
sentiments from Texas that their plan is
absolutely not working and it's killing
people right here in this River and I
don't understand how you can turn a
blind eye to that or put your head in
the sand about that because I know as a
mom I cannot and will not do that do
that and I promise you that I'm going
back to Washington I'm going to do
everything I can to fight this because
again seeing it firsthand I invite
people come down here see it for
yourselves the pictures do not do it
justice
so thank you and I am going to
um
invite my new colleague congresswom
Connie Conway to the podium thank you
thank you and thank you Tony appreciate
this very much you know uh being from
Central California uh I don't have a
border uh but California has a border
every situation is different the
opportunity to be here today and see
this and experience it and talk to the
folks that are directly impacted on both
sides of the Border uh the immigrants
themselves law enforcement that is
dealing with this crisis it's
eye-opening I've seen it on TV it's one
thing to see which is why I appreciate
this opportunity so much to be down here
to uh to see it myself rather than just
what I see on the news and you know I I
believe this is the biggest crisis
facing our nation because it impacts so
many things as you've heard all the
numbers and all the information from my
colleagues how they're impacted I know
in the central California where I live
it's an agricultural area
it's just two weeks ago uh Two Gentlemen
were stopped well guys were stopped with
150 000 fentanyl pills and 18 hours
later they're let go and of course they
didn't return for their appointed court
date so border or no border this impacts
every single life every single person in
this country and for the life of me I
cannot understand this Administration
they either think we're stupid when they
tell us uh no it's all good you know we
got it under control
do you really think the American people
don't realize that's not true and why
they won't come down I don't get that
either you know I'll pay for the plane
flight uh not on Air Force One but uh
come down here please do not ignore the
situation this is American crisis the
cartels as we've heard they're the big
Winners they are financially backing a
lot of this uh something has to change
like my colleagues I'm committed to that
change and want to see what's best for
this country what's best for the Border
countries and do something and do it
soon thank you Tony
yeah we'll uh open it up for a few
questions
yes sir
you know a couple months ago uh Bishop
Evans special or Sergeant Bishop Evans
was not rescued and he drowned right
behind us here in Eagle Pass just a few
feet from us this this Soldier lost his
life defending this border and that
chaos has not stopped for one moment we
almost lost another Soldier today what
is it going to take you know 155
migrants migrants get fished out of that
that River every single day many of them
innocent people making a dangerous Trek
just looking for a better life for
themselves everyone has been sucked up
into this chaos Congressman Ferguson
mentioned it earlier there's enormousy
that is happening this should not be
normal
saving soldiers from drowning in a river
in Texas is not normal
what is it going to take for this
Administration to wake up and turn
around and say your policies are broken
you've got a group of people here that
are ready to work with you let's find a
solution to it we're not looking
politically through it we're my people
my people in this season in this
District we need help today not with
just Republicans Or democrats we need
help what is it going to how many people
are going to die 53 people in my
District 53 migrants cooked to death in
a truck imagine being the first
responder and you respond to that crisis
you never can get that smell out of your
mind
these are the things that My First
Responders are dealing with every day
Congressman Ferguson you have any
thoughts to say on on uh you know the
fact that a a national Guardsman almost
drowned yeah the fact that we're
dividing Administration has created the
environment that makes it less safe not
only for our citizens but for our law
enforcement offers officers is
unconscionable for the administration
again to turn a blind eye to What's
Happening Here should infuriate every
single American because it's having a
real impact on their lives these
officers that have put in their lives at
risk every single day also happen to be
fathers or mothers brothers and sisters
it is they have families to go home to
they have people that they love and
people that love them and they are they
are being put at risk because of
policies that Joe Biden and this
Administration continue to back that put
America more and more at risk and for
what reason what's Happening Here you
ask yourself why is this going on why
when when you when you look at failing
to to to deal with border security and
legal immigration you know who the big
winner in it all is
the drug cartels
not Republicans not Democrats not Mexico
not America it's the drug cartels and so
the question's got to be raised is why
is the administration allowing the drug
cartels which are narco-terrorists
organizations to win instead of
Americans it's unconscionable and we
have to put a stop to it
yes
three times
one time
yesterday
for OLS
every single day
they are Bad actors that are crossing
this River
every single day
and these Bad actors are going to all
parts of the country these are people we
do not want and nobody wants in their
neighborhood
also every single day you've got
innocent people that are fleeing
terrible situations that are crossing
that River
and they're mixed together and because
border patrol agents are in processing
centers and they're not out in the field
we don't know who's who and that's the
most dangerous thing the number one
thing border patrol agents ask me is
just get me back in the field so I can
catch bad people that want to do bad
things to innocent folks and because
they're not in the field they can't do
that and we can't rely sheriffs police
Chiefs DPS agents to fill the Gap what
is it going to take
you know secretary mayorkas visited my
office three weeks ago and I asked him
for many things but there was one thing
in particular that I asked him for I
said Mr secretary this goes away if you
re-implement repatriation flights what
does that mean there's a brand new
processing center here in Eagle Pass
thousands of people get processed there
you know what it's missing it's missing
an immigration portion to it where
people get their case heard in days not
years and if you don't qualify for
Asylum you get sent back to your country
of origin right that enforces it this
goes away with that in the same breath
this Administration needs to think about
legal immigration
I met with Amendment farmers and
ranchers two days ago and they're going
Tony there's thousands of people coming
through our sector but yet I can't find
workers to help in the field these
people are going elsewhere because there
is no legal immigration process it is
completely broken this Administration
has doubled down on illegal immigration
and innocent
migrants are getting sucked up into the
chaos and drowning
an innocent
people innocent Americans are having to
live with these these Bad actors that
are making it everywhere uh Julia
well what's absolutely heartbreaking is
the migrants trying to cross this River
and the babies that are drowning but
what's terrifying as a mom is the 140
000 getaways that we don't know who they
are where they went could be in my state
of Louisiana coming after my children
and yours that is absolutely terrifying
something has to change something has to
stop for the safety of my children and
for yours
do we have any other questions
I'm a father of six and I'm a father
before I'm a congressman and as a father
uh I'm concerned about my children going
back to school I'm concerned with school
safety I represent the district 23 Texas
23rd District 119 cities and towns and
I'll tell you every single one of them
is concerned about going back to school
the closer you are to the border the
more you see these bailouts it used to
be once a month then it was once a week
now it's three times a week and in some
cases it is daily so what does that
happen the the parents the teachers
everyone the the children you become
numb to it it becomes normal there's
nothing normal about a school going into
lockdown there is nothing normal about a
high-speed chase going through a small
town and it's no longer it's a matter of
time before someone dies people are
dying every single day every single day
so I would tell you know every Community
we met with the mayor of Eagle Pass
earlier today and we had this discussion
and every Community is going what do we
have to do in order to make sure our
parents our our parents feel as if they
are uh you know they are ready for the
school year
right do we have any uh any other
questions one last question if there's
any other questions
okay all right thank you thank you
everybody
who's is this Mike